hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game it's from round six
of the 2018 but to me chess olympiad
sorry about this this is for later it's
a game between if a clear mama JA Revere
already seen a very nice game between
him and LaVon our Union and thank you
all for that
explanation in the comments how his
t-shirt with the cat on it actually
means catastrophe but even though he
lost his game against the momma Dee are
of that game was nowhere near a
catastrophe so I didn't I didn't figure
it out so thank you for that and it does
make sense now here am a mural is facing
the strongest check a grandmaster david
navara so it's a azerbaijan versus the
czech republic a very very nice game and
it's i'll go into the title of the video
a bit later so without further ado let's
check out this very nice game mama deriv
with the white pieces opens with d 4 d 4
we have Knight to f6 Knight to f3 and d5
c4 and d6 again transposing into the
Queens gambit declined Knight to c3 and
c5 now we have pawn captors on d5 Knight
captures on d5 Navarra signalized that
he is willing to exchange everything he
for Knight captures on c3 be captors on
c3 see captors on d4 see capture son d4
and even Bishop to b4 check we have
Bishop to d2 blocking Bishop captures
Queen captures and here Navarre castles
so if you look at this position straight
out of the opening gets only moved 10
it's a very theoretical line at one very
interesting detail is all up until move
17 we're gonna get back to that they
didn't really it's it's an
understatement to say that they were
blitzing out the moves because they were
spending like a second or two for a move
perhaps for some moves like 6 seconds I
think the most that was penned was 30
seconds on the move all up until
move 17 so this is how much a
theoretical line
this is and both of them are
very well prepared Bishop to c4 so if
you look at this position either the
opening black didn't manage to exchange
some pieces you know there is not a lot
of tension white it does have a stronger
Center but the black does have a two
against one point advantage on the Queen
side so white will try to plan the King
set in the center and the black if he
will be able to develop then he will
look for his chances on the Queen side
of course so let's see how Navarre does
it feed volts Knights to be seven I
would have castles by mom and ER of b6
preparing to develop the light square
Bishop rook a to d1 and the bishop to b7
are just normal developing moves rook F
to e1 looked the c8 Bishop to b3 getting
the bishop out of the way
rook to e8 and now h 3h 6a both of them
making some room for the forger Kings
Queen to f4 and here comes the first
move that took a bit longer here Navarre
took three and a half minutes for this
Queen to c7 move navara offers a trade
of Queens and if you accept the trade of
Queens it's basically a draw offer for
example if Queen captures rook captures
you can go d5 captures captures rook
room defends rook rook captures rook
captures and now white would have a
passed pawn and a pass to D pawn but it
would be very hard to push for something
from this position and one black
stabilizes he will be able to push his
pawns on the Queen side as he does have
the advantage here on the other hand
after this Queen to c7 move this
position was already on the board for
example it was already on the board in
2018 in women's Russian championship
between a Lisa gallium OVA and paulina
Halawa where Queen to h4 was played and
white was able to win this game here
Mahmoud Arif finds a different idea he
also avoids the Queen trade as he
doesn't want a draw with the white
pieces he blocks with E 5 and now the
game continues Mammadov took some over
10 minutes to play this move I think it
was somewhere around 11 minutes so the
first move where mama D are actually had
to think what do you do here well by
playing e5 okay you do avoid the Queen
trade but you open up the
Black's LightSquared Bishop which now
becomes a very strong piece on the other
hand you also weaken the d5 square white
slide square bishop is also very strong
so now you have to figure out what you
want to do navara goes Knight to f8 and
it's a very nice idea now you want to go
get the knight over to g6 were it comes
to g6 for the tempo and from there it
will be a very nice defensive piece and
perhaps in the future it can come to e7
and perhaps d5 or f5 but navara wanted
it to go to f8 and then to g6 if he
wanted it to go to d5 immediately he
could have just played in Knight to f6
the pawn cannot capture the knight as
Queen captures Queen as possible and
then after white tries to dislodge the
Queen for example then comes Queen Queen
to b8 and now whatever plan why is this
a wide decides to go for probably in 92
as now the d6 square is available for
whites Knight this would definitely be a
plan but black could definitely get a
hold of this d5 square if this was
Nevarez plan but Navarro decides against
it so he goes Knight to f8 we have
Knights to d2 mama D off plans either
most likely not tonight
efore because the black will not allow
this nice to come to d6 so he will
perhaps definitely capture it but
Knights the c4 the d6 is definitely an
idea so you have to prevent it Knight to
g6 first with an attack against the
Queen Queen to g4 and now b5 you do have
to prevent this Knight from jumping to
c4 nice to e4 now definitely the thread
is nice to be six the fork the rooks so
you do have to capture it but rip
captures that we have Queen captures and
now comes a five so navara seems to have
stabilized the position and now he
starts playing on the Queen side where
he has the the pawn majority d5 by
Mahmoud yarv
a very nice move because you really have
to see what happens if a 4 is played a
faith if a forest played immediately
then pawn captures here you give up the
bishop but only temporarily pawn
captures Bishop and now comes rook to d7
with an attack on the Queen and also
preparing pawn captures on f7 after
Queen captures on e5 e captures on f7
with check you have to move the King
King h7 now comes capturing with the
Queen rook captures and now
it would be very easy to at the blunder
with Queen captures Queen now after a
night night captures here you can't play
a capture some b3 with the idea I did ok
the night cannot capture your look
because its pinned but Knight to f3 is a
possibility and now pawn captures rook
captures here and here even though white
is up up upon with such a terrible pawn
structure black would be able to hold
this to a law but after this rook a
personage simply don't capture but
simply move the Queen for example Queen
III and now this B to pawn will not be
all that powerful
there's no way to support it because the
other be pawn is in the way so white
would have a very nice winning position
here so after d5 now we have it captures
on d5 first rook captures on d5 and only
not a4 and okay brush up to d1 we have
Queen to b7 now preparing for a queen
trade rush up to f3
we have Knight to e7 now forcing a Queen
trade look to the 6 Queen captures
Bishop captures and here we have the
critical moment in the game Navarro has
to figure out how to go about this he
still has the advantage on the Queen
side definitely a moves like B 4 and B 3
would be favorable for him one advantage
that mamedyarov has is the advantage of
bishop against a knight the the place on
both sides of sides of the board so a
bishop is definitely you know a better
piece here and we remove like rook to b8
preparing B for B 3 navara would still
be definitely very much in this game but
instead after this Bishop to b4 moving
over a plate Knight to g6 so this wasn't
this wasn't the greatest of ideas
another idea was if Bishop captures then
pawn captures and if rook captures yes
white does win a pawn but before his
coming and the very soon black would
also have a passed pawn that will
already be on b3 rook to b8 will
definitely be a plan and this was most
likely Nevarez reasoning but after this
night the g6 move he missed one very
nice move by mami
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the move mama D off plate
I'll give it a couple of seconds for you
as usual for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations you are truly
an excellent player and for those who
just want to enjoy the show
mama DRF played pawn to e6 and it seems
very reasonable
you cannot capture here because then
your night is free for grabs and so you
do have to figure out what to do here
possibilities are 92 e7 and the Knight
to f4 and both are both are okay another
one goes for Knight to f4 but here comes
the problem he captures on f7 with check
King captures on f7 and now comes g3 and
now you see that black really doesn't
have all that many options what do you
do here if you go knife to e6 you simply
get pinned brush up to d5 and there's a
triple attack against your knight
there's no way to add more defenders you
simply lose the piece here ended the
game on the other hand after g3 if you
go something like 90 to h5 then simply
brush up to g6 again winning King has to
move simply rook captures a nice forcing
line and now it all depends on what kind
of a person you are do you want to grab
the rook and then be up the exchange or
grab the night and be up a piece your
choice really but you know anything you
do b6 the pawns are now falling down
there's nothing to do here so after g3
navara goes for the only line available
to him he goes King to e7 simply attacks
the rook and now the rook has to move
and only then will he move the knight we
have rook to d2
now the knight can move we have Knight
to c6 and it's not really a great square
for the knight because the King is now
an e file in front of Medea of the rook
rook the d5 first attacking the b5 pawn
so what do you do here before you do
have to defend it if you lose the the
advantage on the Queen side then you're
just worse until the end of the game and
Mamedov goes F for a very nice move at
some point that he's definitely
preparing f5 and it's not all that easy
to stop f5 you can't really move the
King the D file is covered by the rook
and you you have to play something if
you try to move it
example King to f7 you're just gonna get
a rope to f5 check now you can't go here
because of all the discoveries if you go
back to g8 you're just gonna get pinned
would match up to d5 so you just have to
go back and then you get roughed to b5
attacking the pawn if you lose the pawn
the game's over
so after work to be a the defending he
would simply capture capture and after
Bishop to b5 you would again pin this
Knight rook would defend it but then f5
wins it definitely so not not all that
easy to pair this paradis f5 move
navarro tried it would be three as the
line we've just shown doesn't work for
black so after b3 we have a capture some
b38 capture some b3 and now feel free to
pause the video again and find the move
that wins the game for mommy dr off I'll
give you a couple of seconds to decide
what we want to do it or not as usual
for those of you who are able to do it
and who were able to solve the first one
as well
truly congratulations you are really an
amazing player and for those of you just
want to enjoy the show if you found f5
f5 doesn't work because after f5 9th to
c5 comes the bishop is under attack and
there are no good discoveries because
your rook and pawn are blocking your own
Bishop there's no rush up to g6
discovery winning the rook or anything
the movie had to find was actually
Bishop to g6 which is Mahmud II are what
Mahmud y'all have played in the game
moving the bishop with an attack against
the rook and here it doesn't really
matter of course you have to move the
rook but it doesn't matter worry more if
you move it here the idea is pretty
simple like I like the move that was
actually played in the game for example
rook to e5 a double attack against the
night once the knight is defended simply
f5 you attack it again after black
pushes b2 you will simply exchange
everything here you are now up a piece
and after up the c1 you will simply
ignore it King to f2 and now I have to
loop capture screen captures and King
captures you will have a bishop that is
guarding b1 and you are of course
completely winning here so after this
Bishop to g6 move navara try to rope to
f8 but the idea is pretty similar simply
f5 immediately pinning attacking the pin
piece
rook to f6 defending and now comes rook
captures on e6 rook captures pawn
captures and here B to mommy jar of
Claybrook to b5 you have to put a rope
behind the passed pawn King to f6
attacking the bishop bishop to h7 and
after Bishop to h7 and move 41 David
navara resigned the game so a great
victory for a Shia Imam in Europe and a
great victory for Azerbaijan who are now
soul leaders well not really so leaders
but they are on top as you see
Azerbaijan and Poland so it will be
definitely a clash of titans in around
7:00 sharp Imam Yara will face Duda who
is having an amazing tournament and
really mommy tiara will be a true test
of skill for him there's really nothing
to do here rook to c1 check will be met
with King g2 and now you're not in you
can't give a check you have to keep an
eye on the b2 pawn and there's the black
simply isn't in time to do everything if
you try to trap the bishop with g6 I
simply wrote capture some b2 and after
King to g7 rook the b7 check is coming
that you can't capture the bishop I have
to remove the King East 7 and it is all
over for black so yeah after Bishop to
h7 a wonderful victory for Mahmud Arab
and he's really gaining up on rating him
in Caruana
if they continue playing like this they
might even catch up the course until the
end of the Olympiad highly unlikely but
you know anything can happen
and this is what I meant by the title of
the video this just away me get to it
after Bishop to e4 like we said with
rook to b8 you can simply start pushing
here and white will be better
a bishop will be better than a knight
but with two-to-one advantage on the on
the Queen side you want to start pushing
your pawns as soon as possible so this
is what I meant Knight to g6 how come in
your own games or perhaps if you're
playing a tournament and the Navara is
over 2700 raided
how come your opponent that that would
be rated let's say 1500 1700 1920 123
300 you think he
of course he would play rook to b8 and
start pushing the pawn why would he play
Knight to g6 and wonder like this and
you might even ask yourself how come
David Navarro over 2700 raided the Grand
Master would would do something like
this well that's because my media really
is playing like an engine he's making
him think every move and he has to play
it out to perfection to match my
Madhav's play and this is very tiring
move after move after move after move
you have to spend more and more time and
really calculate everything because you
know mama dro is playing like a machine
and this will tire you and the end
result will be such a mistake like
Knight to g6 that allows a 6 and it's
seems like seems like a silly move for
black to make but it's not all that hard
to believe when when you see how much
white is is pushing you to to think and
to play the game to perfection so yeah
just something I wanted to mention
because it's really a really a
theoretical struggle all the way to move
17 like we mentioned then that if I move
and only only then did the player start
wasting time so really this Knight to g6
really really an amazing way to have to
give up with the game and such an
important game in the Olympiad but yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and that you're enjoying the coverage of
the Olympiad so far like we said today
is gonna be a feisty battle between mama
dren Duda and also Croatia is currently
18 but they are facing United States who
are currently number three it will be a
really an excellent opportunity for even
charge of who's playing board one for
Croatia to take a shot at
Fabiano khurrana rochak championship
challenger as sharukh already defeated
magnus carlsen in the Olympiad once so
it would be it would be it's definitely
a nice opportunity for him very eager to
see how that ends up so that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Jason Teague Henry Gabrielson John
Armani Marshall Andrade and Brian
calling for a conversion to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
I will see you soon hopefully with
another interesting video and yes we
will return to the Bobby Fischer series
as soon as we cover a deal Olympiad and
if I get a bit more time throughout the
day I'm gonna throw in a Fischer video
as well so thank you all and I'll see
you soon